Caroline's with us in Montgomery Alabama
hi Carolyn how are you I'm good thank
you I'm good yeah I need some advice for
the nastiest bill collector person I've
been through all of them used your you
know call and make an offer and this one
I put off because they've been horrible
it's called my employer they call my
kids they're horrible and although I
know they've sold it a couple times and
it's come down they are saying that they
can't settle for less than the original
debt because this was one of those deals
where they email you and tell you that
they'll put it directly in your checking
account
this was my truly most desperate moment
and so today I said oh my credit bureau
credit the cause it says it's like 390
they're saying oh we won't take less
than for something and I offered them
25% and they said nope we can't take any
less than the whole mouth because it
involves your checking account and by
the way we can come get you for this
blah blah blah they can't come get you
you're talking about a payday lender
yeah but I never actually went into a
store it was actually all online yeah
but it was essentially a payday lender
you wrote a check in advance right I
didn't write it back I mean gave them
access in advance you gave them
permission right money out two weeks
from now and in return you got money now
correct yeah that's a payday lender
online play lender albeit but and no
that's not true they can take less if
they want and no it's not true they
cannot come after you criminally they
can't come after you criminally for
writing a hot check because their entire
business model is written is built on
hot checks sure and so anybody anybody
in the legal profession or anybody in
the law enforcement profession will tell
you that you have not broken any laws so
you can put that that's a lie the second
thing is they can they can take less
there's not a law that says they can't
take less I won't take less is could be
a real answer or we won't take less but
we can't take less is just not true
gotcha of course they can they just
won't come down they called me a couple
years ago and $1,000 and now it's four
and I just said okay I'll go down to the
next person on my bills and talk to you
later bye
how many
how many more debts do you have probably
two because they will my person asking I
really put off talking to them okay yeah
and what's happening is is they're
getting the reverse of what they hoped
for they hope for beating you into
submission instead what they're getting
is nothing because you're you're just
always thinking you're the last person I
want to give money to correct yeah so
it's working in Reverse um that happens
with some of these guys hmm
what is your household in what's your
household income I'm about forty
thousand okay alright and the other two
debts amount to how much four thousand
and I think about 650 650 dollars
correct okay all right well I would go
ahead and get the $650 one worked out
next and let them sit sitting for years
hasn't softened them that much though so
you're probably going to end up giving
them four hundred bucks at some point
and of course you know the drill you do
not give anyone electronic access to
your checking account I have prepaid
credit card thanks for your advice
Mariano sure this event so that there
are no access to your checking account
and you do not give them any money
unless it's in writing correct
settlement amounts in writing okay well
thank you they're probably going to have
a hard time getting that out of these
guys too because you are dealing with
bottom-feeders you're dealing with a
scum I have that sense I have that sense
well good I'll just let them fit and I
might even try to work out the four
thousand before I go back to home that's
fine or you know at any time you call me
and I've got four or I've got $300 or
whatever my offer is I'll do it but
until then I don't really anything to
discuss with you so you can call all day
long you're gonna get a dial tone hang
up on you I've been allowed to call your
children I must have mixed them up I
don't know where they got their numbers
I would send them a certified mail
return receipt requested letter stating
that they're not allowed to contact you
at work anymore according to the Federal
Fair Debt Collection Practices Act that
your employer has asked you not to take
calls at work and then if they call you
at work again record it because you can
probably get the entire debt waived
if I read menu if you continue to have
trouble with them go to collection bully
comm collection bully comm and that's a
group of attorneys that will go after
collectors that are out of bounds on
federal law these guys are probably out
of bounds on federal law but it's not
much money and so on and you owe it so
I'd probably just pay the 400 if you can
get them settled but if they continue
these out of bounds like calling kids
calling you at work
calling relatives calling neighbors and
everybody knows they're a collector
which means they've broken federal law
and so that that's when you would jump
on them with collection bully calm
thanks for the call
you